ومن اسباب السعاده الى عمر التعاسه اذ
يبدو ان الشعور بالتعاسه والحزن لا يتعلق
باللحظات التي يمر بها الانسان بشكل فردي
المساله تتعلق بالحاله العامه للعقل
البشري وذلك بحسب دراسه حديثه نشرت في
مجله بيترا الالمانيه حددت اكثر المراحل
العمريه يا عسل نتائج الدراسه تقول انه
بغض النظر عن الحاله الاجتماعيه المهنيه
والاكاديميه
ضد من
حنى وفق هذه الدراسه يصل الاشخاص في اواخر
الاربعنات من العمر الى اعلى مستويات
التعاسه وتحديدا يفصل الاشخاص لهذا
المستوى في الدول الصناعيه في السنه
السابعه والاربعين عاما وفي البلدان
الناميه يصل الى ادنى مستوى من السعاده
عند 48 عاما على كل حال سنبحث عن السعاده
واسرارها في شوارع عمان معك يا عماد
[موسيقى]
كنا نسمع دائما ان الحياه تبدا في سن
الاربعين وكنا دائما نشعر بان السعاده
تلحقيقيه لم تترك بابنا بعد ولكن ماذا عن
التعاسه
[موسيقى]
حساب
دراسه جديده نسفت كل ما سبق باظهارها ان
الاشخاص في اواخر الاربعينيات من العمر
يصلون الى اعلى مستويات التعاسه وليس
السعاده فما السبب
[موسيقى]
بعد الاربعين
اكثر من عاطفته
في الموضوع سعادته
[موسيقى]
احد الاربعين خلص في منه نبلش المرهقه مع
بعض ما بعد سن الاربعين بالضبط انا هيك
ملاحظه
اما التفسير العلمي للشعور بالتعاسه في
هذه المرحله العمريه يعود الى ان الاشخاص
والاهداف في الحياه تتطور مع مرور الوقت
[موسيقى]
فبعكس العشرينيات في الاربعينيات من العمر
تساؤلات عده تشغل وتفكير المرء حول اهداف
الحياه بعد هذا العمر وحول جدول استمرار
فيما هو عليه او تجربه شيء اخر كذلك
تساؤلات حول مكان العيش والامان الماليه
وكان الدنيا التي يفترض ان تكون لطيفه
وخفيفه تكشر عن انيابها اكثر من قبل
هذه نصف الحقيقه فالنصف الاخر هو ان
كثيرين يشعرون في منتصف العمر بضروره
استعاده شبابهم والاستمتاع بالحياه رجاله
ونساء ولعلنا نكتشف في النهايه ان لكل
مرحله عمريه سعادتها الخاصه لصباح العربيه
عماد عدايله عمه
طيب في السعوديه
الدكتور نادر ياغي دكتور يسعد صباحك اهلا
يا اخي طيب اهلا بك يا دكتور طيب دراسه
بتقول انه في اواخر اربع ايام
هل فعلا هذا ما يحصل ان ذلك ليس مرتبط
ولكن
في حاجه او نظريه
اكثر جراه اكثر مغامره طفوله
المراه
لازم اعمله
صار عندنا التزامات كثيره جدا كان عندنا
الجراه نحن ممكن نلبس اللي احنا عاوزينه
ناكل في الشارع نعملها اشياء كثير عملناها
مجنونه ومغامرات غير طبيعيه فهي دايما
بيعتبروا احسن مرحله تكون الانسان فيها
سعيد لما يعمل الثلاث اشياء هذول اقل
التزاما اكثر جراه اكثر مغامره
اولاد شغل منيح يعني هو الاسعد
اكثر
صار في عندي اولاد انا مسؤول عن الاولاد
انا في عندي عمل وفي عندي مرتبات وفي عندي
اشياء كل هذه الاشياء تخنق الاشخاص شوف
احنا هنتكلم بصراحه
اشوفهم الان بدا يفكر في المغامره
طيب انت ايام مراهقتك ايام المدرسه
فهو ما عنده الان
شبه نحنا بنقولها زي المراهقه المتاخره
انه بده يحاول يعمل مغامرات غريبه بالنسبه
للمراهقه والشباب دكتور دراسه تقول انه
لما يوصل انسان الى مرحله الاربعينيات
يصير يفكر فيها اهداف جديده ويفكر يعيش
حياه سعيده بعيدا عن مشاكل الحياه اليوميه
هل هي ازمه منتصف العمر
دائما احنا بنقول في وقفه مهم جدا في
الحياه الوفاه تبعت ال 40 او ال 42 المهم
اللي بعد ال 40 هي وقفه بسيطه جدا بيكون
قاعد ساعات انا طبعا عملت بالوراء والقلم
بس في ناس ما بتعملها بيكون قاعد بيبلش
يفكر انا متجوز عندي اولاد طب انا اولادي
كيف مبسوطين انا دخلتهم الجامعه
في حياته هي هي اهم اهم مرحله في حياتنا
دائما المرحله اللي بعد ال 40 لان احنا
خلاص وصلنا الى بعد منتصف العمر ودخلنا في
حاله التزامات كتير فهي هذه الكارثيه في
هذا الوقت اللي بتصير فيه المشكله انك انت
بتصير بدنا نعرف انهي مرحله في ناس
بتفكروا بيقول لك انا احلى مرحله في حياه
الطفوله اه انت شوف فاكر من الطفوله انا
فاكر ان الطفوله كنا بنلعب كنا بنعمل طب
المراهقه لا كانت صعبه وهكذا فهي كيف
تتربط احنا السعاده او المراحل الجميله
اللي كان فيها ذكريات جيده هل
الحاله كئيب بطبعه يعني مهما كان عمره
ومهما كانت المرحله العمريه
مع صاحباتك والناس اللي تعرفين في حياتك
احنا اللي بنخلق التعاسه يعني انا في اقول
لك عمري ما حدا بيقدر يصدق انا عمري في
ناس انا باشوفهم في نفس العمر اللي انا
فيه بيقعد يحكوا لي انه انت عامل البوتوكس
ما باعرف عامل كذا كذا انا عامل سوري
وتجاعيد غير طبيعيه وهو شايف الحياه غير
طبيعي وطول الوقت في معاناه مع العلم عنده
بحبوحه من المال عنده كل يعني كل الاشياء
اللي ممكن تكون الانسان
طول ما انا هافكر في اشياء فقدتها وانا
عمالي بفكر فيها هفقد اشياء جميله بتصير
في حياتك فانا دائما باقول ها ما تفكر في
المفقود عشان لا تفقد الموجود الحياه ابسط
مما يمكن انا ممكن ساعات تكون في اكله
سعادتي في اي مكان انت رحت الهواء قلت لي
شو سعادتك انا ما عندي ساعات محدده في شيء
معين همم القاعده انا عشان بس قبل اللي هو
ما تخلص القاعده ده بنقول ان احنا ما نقول
لا شيء اي شيء ممكن يجيء لك في حياتك ما
تقول له لا لانه جرب في ناس كثير حتى مرات
بيجيء بقدم لهم حاجه اكله معينه بتقول لي
لا انا ما بحب الاكل هذا اللي متعود على
كذا طب جرب جرب شيء
السعاده لحظات بس انا ممكن اخليها تستمر
السعاده انت اللي ممكن تخليه يستمر يعني
انت السعاده ان انا هلا المفروض عندي رحله
على دوله معينه ماجلها بقى لي فتره هي
الرحله ممكن بس تخليه اربع ايام بس انا في
الاربع ايام هادي ممكن انا اصنع منها
ذكريات لمده سنه واثنين انا دائما بقول في
اشخاص بيروحوا الملاهي بيروحوا على
المناطق الترفيهيه هو رايح على المنطقه
الترفيهيه
همم وهو رايح المنطقه الترفيهيه بيكون
وقتها قاعد بس بيعمل مشاكل يعني
ما بتخليه لا لا على سلامتك ههه